all right what's up buddy
hey can you hear me yeah
hey uh thanks for taking my calls
actually my first time watching live but
uh
um recently I was in a relationship that
lasted six years I'm not gonna get too
much into it I was
one it is pretty bad and I ended up
buying not by getting a couple credit
cards trying to save the relationship
type deal
you were trying to save a relationship
with credit cards well it was more of
the what I was doing with the credit
cards like what I was buying what I what
I was trying to take her to do you know
was it like buying her experiences by
her love buy her gifts yeah kind of like
a yeah just like that and so you tried
to say the relationship by buying her
stuff yeah yes that didn't work
obviously it did not okay so what
happened next
um yeah I just uh
spent a lot of money with the credit
cards and now I'm kind of paying the
price for it like literally
and I I kind of want to wanted wanted to
ask because I missed the beginning part
of the show like what what kind of like
strategy should I do I'm like 11k right
now and I'm already you know I got a son
and I'm moving into a new place and so
money's already tight and just trying to
think of maybe some strategies or some
something I can get in my head that your
your son's mother was a woman that you
were in the six year relationship with
no actually no no my son is nine so he
was born a little bit before okay so the
six-year relationship is not your son's
mother
no no so she's gone but you have the
debt from that relationship yes yeah and
that and and it's funny I don't want to
get into it but but yeah yeah basically
that's it okay so what's the question
here like what's the best way to handle
it yeah like I heard you mention
bankruptcy and I don't know much about
it I probably should be looking more
into it um where do you live in Canada
I mean I've been uh California okay and
it's only eleven thousand dollars
yeah it's like well and then I got my
student loans but those I'm still in
school so I'm not paying that right now
and kind of just
focusing on my car because I can't I
can't lose that so it's car and then
isn't it isn't it interesting that
student loans are really the only debts
that you can't go bankrupt on
yeah go to school go get that education
but if you screw up you know with your
credit you can never really go bankrupt
on that stuff
even if you die your family has to pay
something no
um unless they've unless they've
co-signed for a loan nobody else is
liable when she died once you die at the
debtstop it's like you know
um there used to be debts that would
show up in collection agencies and you
and you'd call them up and be like yeah
he died two years ago and then all you
really needed was a copy of the death
certificate death certificate and then
they would just discharge the debt it
would just shut up it would just go away
sort of thing
um so as far as 11 Grand like are you in
school full-time you're a full-time
student or do you work right now too uh
no I'm actually at work right now but um
I work full time and I'm a student
online school right now so you make good
money like what's your income like uh
it's it's okay for where I live but it's
it's I'm still
struggling I guess you could say
struggling and what's your annual then
uh it's like 50 50k okay so the first
question that I would ask when I was
dealing with this in my Depends was is
what you're doing right now paying down
the balance and if so
let's deal with that first so is it
getting paid down
um I've been paying minimum basically
like you're
saying earlier I've been doing the
minimum payments so you haven't seen it
go down there no I haven't just go down
in quite a bit okay so that plan clearly
doesn't work what are the interest rates
uh the biggest one is they're like 20 26
26 20 28 there's two of them that are
the main ones okay so I mean guys the
first lesson here is don't try to buy
your way out of a sinking relationship
by buying her stuff or experiences
because now she's gone and he's dealing
with the consequences of this right
so as far as options go 11 Grand is not
that much
if you can put more on it to pay it off
within the next six to 12 months I would
I would do that right to go bankrupt for
eleven thousand dollars wouldn't make a
lot of sense right
um if you had no assets whatsoever or if
you had assets that were exempt from the
bankruptcy you know for example like if
your vehicle's old it's worth a few
thousand dollars it's probably going to
be exempt from the bankruptcy right like
you'll be able to keep it
um tools the trade you know household
items stuff like that you'll probably be
able to keep all of it
in my view I would get a consultation
with a bankruptcy trustee what do they
call them the mistakes a bankruptcy
lawyer
yeah I think so at least at least get a
consultation to see what it would look
like and then I would also get a
consultation with a debt settlement
company uh you live in California
um Freedom Debt relief.com just jot that
down it's owned by my friend Andrew
Hauser he's a good guy I've known him
for years
um I used to I mean we'd have long
conversations about all kinds of stuff
in the debt settlement world back when I
was doing it sort of stuff and his
business is solid so I would recommend
getting a quote from a bankruptcy
trustee and from his debt settlement
company and then just weigh them out and
look at which one looks best for your
scenario
you don't have any assets you don't have
a house you don't have any no just just
my car right now you don't have any
savings or anything like that
no no you don't have any Investments
uh no okay so those would be your two
best options then
cool yeah thank you appreciate it next
time don't try to save a relationship by
buying her heart
okay all right bro take care I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out